we sort of had the same thing in America
already maybe to a lesser extent but
like we have something of a social
credit system where if you say the wrong
thing now like Kanye said I can't use my
Apple pay anymore or even with um like
the digital currency I mean when's the
last time anyone here has bought
something with cash it's been kind you
can't use Apple pay yeah he made a video
he made a video saying specifically he's
running for president of the United
States specifically because Adidas
contacted uh apple and apple shut down
his ability to pay for things yeah which
he said was insane and and they're
punishing the the do you remember
exactly what he said in that video uh I
know I didn't watch it I don't want to I
don't want to paraphrase it but but he
he went on a he went on a rant saying
this is why I want to run for president
of the United States because if they
could do this to me what are they doing
to everyone else this is the meme though
the meme where like the person goes to
the supermarket and then you have to use
your phone to buy something and it says
your credit card has been disabled due
to you know insensitive comments made
online or something and so that's the
thing it's like in China if we live
there yeah they're Draconian and you
can't criticize the government but if
you criticize you know LGBT stuff which
doesn't exist there because they they
ban it it's like you'll be at a greater
Liberty to do things like that and so
this is sort of the problem that America
had we made a calculation where okay if
we open up the markets with China in the
latter half of the 20th century their
their economic Prosperity is going to
make them more liberalized because
everything's going to be fine our
companies are going to go over there and
then it backfired where now you're
empowering this country that is hyper
nationalist frankly racist uh
ethnonationalist and very traditionalist
and now they're going to try to compete
like you said with the US on the world
stage and they're like totally resistant
to all the woke stuff that the U.S wants
to do they made another calculation
where they said okay social media is
becoming very popular we're going to
censor American social media platforms
we're going to build our own
conservatives called that you know
orwellian but now you don't have kids in
China talking about switching their
genders doing things like that because
that's frankly that's like how the US
has soft power in other countries we
have our media companies going and
incepting these ideas into people's
minds and China said no we don't want
that they're doing the same thing to us
though where if you have Tick Tock in
China you're seeing videos of people
that are you know playing piano that are
proficient in the maths and the Sciences
but if you download Tick Tock in America
you get a totally different algorithm
you get very degenerate depraved content
because they're trying to take the youth
which is the future that could maybe
compete with them and just make it
completely demoralized and but now
there's even Democrats saying they want
to ban it yeah which I think is weird
kind of crazy but uh maybe Tick Tock
should have been banned there's a
challenge to this should a company be
able to uh should it should Tick Tock be
allowed to operate an algorithm that is
sending detrimental content to kids or
should our government for national
security reasons be like dude this is
destroying us from the inside out and
take it out and remove it I've had
people Libertarians tell me that I was
being fascist or being authoritarian by
arguing the app should be banned and I'm
like I get it but I've never been an
anarchist or a hardcore libertarian I've
always been kind of just a liberal yeah
yeah but these are not private companies
we have to understand these are
state-run institutions that are running
larger psyopsis that are running what
some would people describe as as fourth
or fifth generational Warfare where
specifically it is used to not only
demoralize but to destroy human beings
attention span destroys people's ability
to to coexist in society destroy
relationships destroy its families this
is the larger consequences of a
government-engineered action and
therefore I would argue it's not a
private company they don't deserve the
protections of a private entity but if
Tick Tock were banned in the U.S
wouldn't something worse just crop up
that is made by Americans like YouTube
shorts yes like YouTube shorts is
somehow lower IQ than Tick Tock and
Instagram reels like something worse
will come up created by Americans and we
don't need China's help becoming you can
sense more demoralizing we're doing this
mostly to ourselves most Libertarians
they're very fine people but they are
usually either like teenagers or like
these sort of disaffected gen xers who
were angry at their dads for like
catching them smoking we in the garage
or something it's just not serious so
yeah I think it should be the straw man
is it yeah yeah yeah we've we've we've
had smart Libertarians on the show
they're I just this smart so here's a
good example um what's his name Austin
Peterson very smart guy very nice
hilarious I was a big fan of him back in
2016. I had a debate with him on a
Elijah Shaffer show and we went back and
forth on libertarianism and what I find
with Libertarians is ultimately because
we agree on what we want the ideal
Society to be you know this
constitutional republic everything is
laid back freedom but where Libertarians
tend to disagree with people like myself
is on what to do with the acquisition of
power how to go about that how to go
about using it and we got into this like
ultimately meaningless back and forth
between like okay how do you want to go
about taking power and then asking power
to delete itself because the other side
wants to take power and use it to like
kill you so there's a great meme I saw
it was on uh uh Patriots of that win the
Donald Forum which I'm sure everybody
else our good friends over Patriots that
win and it was this really crude
paintbrush drawing where it said uh
Democrat vote Republican vote
libertarian vote and it was like demo it
was like Democrats 800 000 Republicans
799 999 libertarian vote two and then it
said winner uh uh no more guns yeah and
it was just like if the Libertarians are
just like okay I guess we have to accept
that this preserves at least some of our
rights then the Republican that being
said you know I get it I I I remember
hearing some conservatives say something
similar to that like Libertarians need
to recognize that voting Republican
preserves more of their rights than not
and I'm like yeah but if the
Libertarians hate you don't expect them
to vote for you figure out how you get
their vote so you you agree on these
core issues ask them what they don't
agree with you on typically you'll find
out it's like war or something so I
think the real opportunity right now is
Donald Trump opposed all of that not
perfectly I know Luke but if we can get
more America First types who are like
hey we don't want foreign intervention
in foreign war you'll see more
Libertarians back okay that that I'll
take the libertarian party is an
absolute joke I absolutely agree with
that candidates or just non-professional
people that made themselves look bad and
made everyone else look bad but if
you're looking at a problem and saying
hey there's a lot of government here
we're going to solve it with more
government that to me is just an idiotic
take that doesn't really make sense to
me as of course you're replacing a
cancer with more cancer when in reality
I think the biggest basis of a kind of
anarchist perspective which again
counters even the libertarian
perspective is that the solution should
be within personal responsibility within
an individual being the best version of
themselves to of course beat out all the
bull crap out there and not stand and
not be a victim and not be someone that
needs government and not incentivize
more of it in your life and I think
that's kind of the problem with the
libertarian ethos it sort of assumes the
perfectibility of the individual it
gives them almost this opportunity to
like hey you can exist and you can be
trusted with freedom and that may have
been the case in you know the 1700s but
now this Society I mean the founding
fathers said that our constitution was
written for a moral and religious people
it would be wholly inadequate for any
other group of people now the average
American in this country is like this
overweight porn addicted like drug user
and we expect this guy to be trusted
with freedom that was brutal and it's
just it's true and so you're seeing this
all happen and the Libertarians think
that like any power any state power is
bad I would offer the distinction that
we like to use with like gun rights for
example what's the only thing that can
stop a bad guy with a gun a good guy
with a gun you can vote libertarian you
can say hey you should delete the power
you have and they're just gonna be like
okay you're non-threatening that's why
no libertarian unless they want to call
for a revolution which they really like
to do they like to fantasize about these
you know big Mass conflict scenarios
they never get banned from social media
because what they're saying is
fundamentally not threatening because
they're just saying hey State go away
and then you've got people like Trump
people who are more authentically
right-wing saying actually I want to
infiltrate the state kick out the
Communists make it illegal for them to
occupy power and then make the country
great again that's threatening and
that's why those people myself included
get banned maybe we need Iron Fist
libertarianism I disagree with it
totalitarianism I didn't say that in any
form of top-down Central I didn't say
that I didn't say that I said Iron best
libertarianism meaning where you gotta
lube it up or something yes
[Music]
I'm kidding calm down look you're
freaking out before I even explained
what I mean I mean a Libertarian party
that respects the rights of the
individual that enshrines the rights of
the individual guarantees them within
the confines of the law and recognizes
they have to be threatening to those
that would seek to destroy and and steal
the power from the people like the point
I'm trying to make is the founding
fathers I think were that they were like
the the the the individual is the you
know the smallest minority and people
have these rights and here's the Bill of
Rights and we're going to war with
Britain to secure them now the
libertarian party is like guys guys guys
you know hold on there a minute we
shouldn't do that because that goes
again star values and it's like okay
the Libertarians that oppose borders I
think are silly sorry like I understand
what you mean when you're like borders
are imaginary lines I had an argument
with this libertarian he's like you
think that imaginary line exists and I'm
like no I think we've asserted we
guarantee and protect our rights and
this is as far as we can protect and are
willing to to enforce upon the land we
have defined the space as what we guard
what is ours and within it we respect
the rights the human rights and the
constitutional rights of the people here
look how do you know I I just refuse to
lick the boot that's just me my own
personal perspective I you make some
very good valid points and I I agree
with you with some of them but at the
end of the day how do we deal with this
kind of fat porn addicted uh loser that
of course is is destroying themselves to
me personally you know people would
argue like hey you know these people who
are victims of this who are going for
the short-term Pleasures are going to
kind of uh ruin themselves not have
families not reproduce this gives
opportunities for people to of course be
the best versions of ourselves but how
do you and and I think you know
incentivizing healthy people families
good diets exercise is something that
should be done but how do you do that on
a state level without being an
authoritarian without being like the
Chinese government yeah uh how do you do
that where's the balance so this is sort
of the problem where the right in the
last 60 years has inherited the worst
parts of libertarianism without the good
parts of it so like the reason we lose
is because you know we are the graceful
losers the beautiful losers we have
principles we're not going to fight
dirty it's better to lose with dignity
than to play their game and so now we
all have to eat food and use those
calories and convert those into thoughts
about how to argue against children
being like having these surgeries before
that is so unspeakable imagine telling
that to someone 50 years ago like yeah
you're actually going to have to like
Set Side set aside time to think about
arguments as why this shouldn't happen
that's what modern conservatism has
brought to the American people we have
failed to conserve everything up until
like literally now your kids are going
to be taken from you if you disagree
with that that's correct I agree with
you I want to expand on that it's
absolute individualism with no
responsibility yes it is police officers
running away from school shootings it is
the Uvalde cop saying I'm not going in
there it's the security guard part in
Parkland being like I'm gonna run the
other direction I was talking about this
um on one of my segments earlier because
I had a t-shirt it's the rooster that
says stand to your ground and it's our
rooster Roberto Jr he's a cartoon he's
like ah and uh what I said was I thought
it was funny I think roosters are cool
and uh it's kind of interesting to me
that
chicken historically for us in our
colloquial English is a reference to
someone being a coward despite the fact
that roosters will sacrifice their lives
to save their hens we used to look at
what chickens were even a rooster
running full speed towards a fox and
dying like as as cowardly like that's
kind of strange to me how something like
that emerged and then today we don't
even have police officers who are
willing to risk their lives to save
children as it's happening in front of
them I'm like okay we're at the point
where our politicians where our law
enforcement are just like I'm not going
in there I'm not risking my neck for you
yeah and that means Society is broken
because yeah everybody is so atomized
and so selfish and so this is sort of
the problem with it like all of the
things that are from the top down
because we sort of live in this like
ideological cumulative tyranny where
it's not as obvious as the Tyranny that
we were taught by Hollywood to fear
where it's one party that controls
everything all of these corporations all
of these institutions ngos media
academic government they're all on the
same page even if they're not all under
the same flag but they are and it's
usually the pride flag but they still
all are on the same page and they're
believing these things and so they from
the top down are demoralizing the
American people by pushing into their
their eyes at virtually you know
anything you go whether it's
advertisements social media all of this
like depraved content and that's where
you get the escapism where people don't
feel like they have any righteous future
prospects they think it's going to be
harder for them to find a moral spouse
harder for them to start a family to get
a good job without amassing tens of
thousands maybe even hundreds of
thousands of dollars in debt and so
that's the escapism whereas like a man
50 60 years ago would be like ah the
factory town I'm gonna do what my dad
did he would kind of have an idea now
men are like I don't know I'm just gonna
like smoke weed and play video games and
do whatever and that's all just
different forms of escapism and so I
don't think the answer to that problem
is simply like smaller government things
like that you have to actually use some
form of power in this country to cut off
the capacity of evil people to do that
to your native population and that's the
only way that you're ever going to be
able to have a people with a clear mind
who can then pursue Liberty which is
defined in the pre-modern understanding
as just the ability to pursue good
without evil trying to basically like
get in your way I wanna I wanna read a
Super Chat real trick just as it's a
very good one it's from fuke
you and uh they say four white men and
one white woman explaining politics whoa
whoa whoa whoa first of all Luke's a
person of color I'm mixed race surge is
African-American and Mary's a ghost
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time